welcome to the daily climate show coming
up as the uk looks set for another heat
wave who is at risk and to what extent
is climate change affecting our summer
weather
as senior conservatives battle it out
for the leadership the government's
chief scientific advisor briefs mps on
the risks of climate change
and squirrel contraception as a climate
solution yes you heard that right
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world hear from the
people hit hardest by those changes and
report on the race for solutions now
it's hot and getting hotter not just the
forecast for this week of course but for
the rest of the century as the world
burns more fossil fuels the science is
unequivocal and the data is clear the
uk's 10 warmest years on record have all
occurred since 2002.
we'll look at that context shortly but
first we can talk to aisha zahid who is
in richmond in south west london for us
aisha the met office today issuing a
risk to life warning how are people
coping with the heat where you are
well people have been enjoying the
sunshine but also taking precautions of
course this
weather can have adverse effects on
health and be that dehydration heat
stroke heat exhaustion it can also
exacerbate symptoms for people with
underlying conditions like heart and
lung problems as well and heat heat
waves can affect
virtually anyone but there are
particular groups more at risk than
others and that includes elderly people
people who live alone babies and
children people who work outdoors and
like i mentioned people who do have
underlying health conditions as well so
the uk health security agency is really
urging people to be cautious to make
sure they stay hydrated to make sure
they're using sunscreen and try and
avoid going outdoors between 11 in the
morning and 3 o'clock in the afternoon
or trying to avoid direct sunlight at
least because that's when uv rays are at
their strongest
hi sure in richmond in south west london
thanks so much for that update well
let's look at the context here i'm
joined by our science correspondent
thomas moore
thomas we just talked about how the uk's
10 warmest years on record have all
occurred since 2002. this is much more
than just a bit of summery weather isn't
it very much so and if you look at the
the summer temperatures too they're
getting progressively warmer if you look
all the way back more than a century the
five warmest summers
have all been since
1976 and if you look forward and there
is increasing concern about what
happened this century so the met office
has done some analysis of the year 2018
which is a very warm summer the warmest
on on record uh jointly with other years
but they found that a warm summer
of that temperature was 30 times more
likely as a result of all the greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere and if you look
at specific temperatures they believe
that
by mid-century the chances of having a
warm summer
are going to be 50-50 so you'll have a
really warm summer every other year and
by the end of the century the chances of
temperatures going over 40 degrees at
some point in a year will be
once every three to four years it really
is going to be very warm indeed just
really quickly while we've got you this
is really serious people are dying from
climate change yeah very much so if you
look at recent years there's been an
average of 2 000 deaths a year
from heat going forward
the predictions are that that will
increase to 7 000 a year so this isn't
just uncomfortable it really is deadly
thomas more our science correspondent
thank you so much for that well there'll
be plenty of coverage this week about
the heat and the context behind it
together with advice on how to keep cool
all on our website skynews.com
well elsewhere
portugal is also in the midst of a
heatwave with temperatures expected to
reach over 40 degrees tomorrow wildfires
have broken out across northern and
central parts of the country with about
3 000 firefighters battling to control
the flames portugal has already seen
extreme weather this year with a drought
affecting around a quarter of the
country last month
and over in the united states yosemite
national park in california has been hit
by wildfires threatening the largest
grove of sequoia trees the trees are
known for their size and age with one
thought to be more than three thousand
years old well let's get a bit more of
today's climate news now the biggest
pipeline carrying russian gas to germany
has begun annual maintenance work with
flows expected to stop for 10 days but
germany is bracing itself for the
possibility of russia imposing a longer
or even permanent shutdown of the nord
stream pipeline due to tensions over the
war in ukraine the german parliament
recently approved the reactivation of
coal plants following a reduction in gas
supply from russia
well this comes as the eu's climate
chief warned europe is at risk of civil
unrest this winter over high energy
prices franz timmerman said climate
goals would not be met if society
descends into very strong conflict and
strife speaking to the guardian he said
countries should make a short-term
return to fossil fuels to ease tensions
and keep industry functioning
a new birth control plan to reduce the
number of grey squirrels in the uk is
showing promising signs say researchers
the government-backed scheme involves
using a feeder that excludes most other
wildlife to give squirrels an oral
contraception grey squirrels damage
woodlands by stripping bark from young
trees something which could hit efforts
to fight climate change as planting more
trees is a key strategy to reducing
carbon in the atmosphere
well shortly after boris johnson became
prime minister he received a briefing
from the government's chief scientific
advisor which he credits with changing
his mind about climate change today more
mps are receiving a briefing from sir
patrick valance following a campaign
from angus rose who went on hunger
strike outside parliament he only ended
his strike after 37 days without food
when mps were offered the briefing
the uk is currently
aiming to have a vastly disproportionate
share of the globally limited carbon
budget
so i did this hunger strike out of
desperation
to try and secure a livable future for
my five nephews and
niece
um
a good way to understand it i think is
if i was living in ukraine as ukrainian
i'd be risking my life
to defend to protect my family and
community and those people who care
about me well joining me now is the
former editor of the british medical
journal and one of those who has been
pushing for this briefing that's dr
fiona godley fenia thank you so much for
joining us today it seems crazy to me
that this is the first ever high-level
briefing to mps on climate change
it is extraordinary and i agree um i i
suppose we just have to say it's
brilliant that it's happening
and it's a real opportunity for mps from
all parties to hear an official update
on climate science and to understand the
urgency of action and to explore you
know what is happening and what needs to
happen uh because as you've heard you
know earlier on in your show the urgency
is real
um we're talking about hitting the 1.5
degree tipping point into catastrophic
climate change possibly sometime around
2033 on latest estimates that's in 11
years time it's really inconceivable to
think that that is the case
and we've got a very strong consensus
now among scientists and health
professionals that that tipping point
will lead to really catastrophic
consequences for human health and
survival
and what can sir patrick valance tell
mps that they don't already know i mean
there's so much information available
well that's absolutely right and i think
that's one reason why some may think
they need not attend but i think what's
really important one of the things i've
been thinking about is where is the
kovid style response to climate change
you know we had daily updates from sir
patrick rightly so and to chris whitty
um and and others about covid um and
that's the kind of more than that the
level we need in relation to climate
change because the consequences of
catastrophic climate change is so much
greater
around the world but also in this
country so um you know what can he tell
them he needs to give them an update
they need to understand the urgency they
need to see this as a crucial priority
for all politicians uh to lead us
through this very difficult time
and uh we've obviously got the tory
leadership race at the moment what do
you make of what you've been hearing
from those hopefuls and what do you want
to be hearing from them
well i think we have to see this as
beyond party politics of course but we
are at a very interesting moment when a
small number of the general public will
be in a position to vote our next prime
minister into office and i very much
hope that those people will take climate
change as one of their key priorities
we'll listen to the candidates messages
on this we'll understand that the
climate change committee says we're
failing on all but eight we're only um
we're only ahead on eight of the i think
50 or so key indicators for um reducing
our climate burden and those ones we're
failing on our transport
energy efficiency um housing and
public engagement with the whole issue
around climate change so there's an
enormous job to be done if we are really
to to to to prevent what i think you
know will be within our lifetime and
certainly within the lifetimes of our
children and grandchildren
a very much very much more dangerous
place to live and possibly
uh you know unsurvivable temperatures
and very quickly well we've got you do
you think these sorts of meetings these
briefings for mps should become a
regular thing
well i would like to see that and i
think that's something we should applaud
you know the fact that this is happening
i think we would like to see it
happening on a regular basis and a lot
of the tracking that could be done um
you know how are we doing on on reducing
our carbon emissions carbon dioxide
stays in the atmosphere for centuries so
it's not just a question of you know how
we're doing we've got to look at our
historic
carbon emissions as well so i think it
would be a really good thing for our
political leaders to to
to to to be really encouraged by their
constituents uh to to engage with this
and to report back to their constituents
about what they're hearing and what
they're doing about it themselves and as
a par as as within their political
parties
dr fiona godley former editor of the
british medical journal thank you very
much for joining us
thank you and just before we leave you
this is the moment british climber harry
shimon feared for his life as an
avalanche came thundering down a
mountain towards him in kyrgyzstan
global warming may make avalanches like
this much more likely as warming
temperatures destabilise mountain
climates melt glaciers and create more
intense storms that is all from us today
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you next time